Metro Trump kept calling Jeb Bush low energy.
I was laying on the couch and that's fucking me.
He's talking about it.
I'm laying on the couch and I hear about somebody dying in an avalanche and I
watch it on TV and I laughed because I wouldn't have a fucking be dropped off in
a helicopter at the top of a mountain to go snowboarding and then they die.
I'm laughing my balls off eating a bag of chips.
Well the one person,
he's never called anybody anything is Nancy Pelosi.
And people like,
why hasn't he come up with a nickname for her yet?
Yeah.
You know,
cause you can't say content that's going to cost him the election.
That'll cost them 20,
27 said a joke about that.
He's like,
it's countdown until Trump 12
sick ankle talk face.
That's what I call Hillary.
I don't even call her.
Uh,
what,
what kind of a nickname,
if you were going to help him,
like if he hired you like nick,
hello,
I need a solid republican comic to help me with my one liners.
What do you think?
Well,
I call her on my show.
I refer her to the,
uh,
the leathery nippled.
Hmm.
That's too,
too wordy.
We need some pretty good look.
Can we change our day like a lion ted?
Okay.
Yeah.
Fucking naughty.
Nancy.
What did he call Hillary?
Crooked Hillary.
Lying Ted.
How Bout Energy Jeb?
About a yeast infection in heels.
How about lying liberal
fuck stick.
Do you know that she's worth $100 million?
Yes,
I do.
She figured out the little people joke.
She represents the working class.
You know,
she has fucking walls around our matching.
Meanwhile,
people laying their own feces in San Francisco.
Well,
that Laura Loomer chick,
that chick did a handcuff yourself to Twitter.
She hopped Nancy's fence and he started setting up,
uh,
like a migrant camp.
Nancy's slot.
Did you see that?
What happened?
What was the result?
Illegal.
She's doing something illegal.
She's trespassing.
I would say donagey I'll be outside of how it's gone.
This fence is immoral,
right?
Build that wall or don't,
I always think the wall still,
but when we have the machine guns and tanks and flame throwers,
like I cook them.
You don't have to kill.
I'm serious about this.
You're going to laugh because
you don't have to,
but seriously,
I love how we rule out lethal force as far as protecting our board.
That's not even on the plate,
so I,
okay.
It's too many.
It was a pick somebody off as they're climbing event,
but okay.
You something less lethal.
A supersoaker filled with cat piss.